we'll continue this morning with our
ongoing series it's called issues that
matter today we have a closer look at
election hacking and the threat it poses
to our democracy the Intelligence
Committee in January reported we assess
Moscow will apply lessons learned from
its campaign aimed at the u.s.
presidential election to future
influence efforts worldwide Hillary
Clinton's 2016 campaign manager Robby
Mook and Mitt Romney's 2012 campaign
manager Matt Rhodes both ran
presidential campaigns targeted by
foreign hackers together they've started
a new project with Harvard's Belfer
Center called defending digital
democracy it aims to shield elections
from cyberattacks they join us for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning welcome to both of you thanks
for having us so this is really
interesting Matt let me start with you
what what do you think that the average
American doesn't understand about cyber
hacking in our elections I think after
the last election I don't think everyone
understands it's a bipartisan challenge
in 2012 when I was MIT's campaign
manager were actually hacked at the fall
of 2011 and we were told by the FBI that
the Chinese had hacked into our campaign
what the problem was and we didn't make
it big to do about it but we had to
spend precious campaign dollars to up
our cybersecurity Network that was money
that when we got to actual campaign
elections the primary with Newt Gingrich
and Rick Santorum those were resources
we couldn't use it didn't get a lot of
attention why didn't you make a big
to-do about it at the time it wasn't
going to move the ball down the field in
winning the Republican nomination we
talked about it after the election and
so it just didn't give it get as much
coverage and right now you know there's
a lot of campaigns 2018 that are going
to go through similar challenges and
threats they don't want to talk about it
campaigns want to talk about the issues
they're running on it not cybersecurity
hacks you know we use these devices to
do our banking in many cases trust our
health records but the election is about
trust National Trust some countries I
have no Estonia you can vote online and
the internet Australia Canada's played
with us do you think we can ever get to
a place in America where people can vote
with this kind of ease well the
technology will dictate that but I think
the the what you just hit on there Trust
is key and this is why I Matt and I are
working on this together this threat is
real you know
countries and intelligence services are
gonna attack our candidates they're
gonna attack our election officials
we've seen the proof of concept on this
and if we don't deal with it in a
bipartisan way if we don't come together
and say an attack on one is an attack on
all that Trust will erode and we can't
allow passively these countries to
basically become involved in our
elections the way say a super PAC could
how would you describe how cyber hacking
hurt the Hillary Clinton campaign well
first of all as matt said it's really
important to recognize the Hillary's
campaign was probably the most prominent
example but this has been happening and
it's happened to both parties what was
different and and the way the threat has
evolved is they're stealing information
and putting it out into the press and as
matt said we want candidates to get out
there and talk about the issues we want
them to be heard we want the American
people to get that full debate if we
allow foreign countries to steal
information and push it out there we're
not going to have that debate and we're
gonna let those foreign countries decide
what we're talking about we can't do
that
and what concerns you now what concerns
you most Matt now when you look at
future elections yeah well obviously
it's a bipartisan problem and I worry
not as much about the next presidential
campaign in 2020 I worry about that
rising star and you can see a Barack
Obama or a George W Bush coming a mile
away and if some hacker were to go into
their emails and misconstrue some
exchange you could change the course of
history and so that's what really
concerns me what do you guys altom utley
hope to accomplish aside from a white
paper that somebody could put on a show
yeah yeah we you know exactly we want to
do something that's tangible that
actually helped campaigns and one thing
that we're working on is putting
together a document that can be shared
and used by Republican campaigns and
Democrat campaigns a playbook of best
practices from a cyber security
standpoint you got to remember
especially down ballot campaigns in the
movies they're portrayed as these
glamorous places yeah they're not
they're usually a bunch of young kids
ragtag organizations they all bring
their laptops to work and somebody gets
assigned to be the digital director / IT
director and they have to come up with
some way to secure everyone's email
system like Bobby you're the time
there's a role for the FBI in this and
there's a role for US intelligence
agencies I mean the Obama administration
knew for months that Russia was trying
to hack in this election influences this
election it didn't come public with it
until the final weeks of the campaign
does that trouble you well I think the
government has a really important role
to play here and we're certainly
advocating for the government to be an
active partner but part of actually why
Matt and I did this was we saw there
were so many resources in the private
sector to deal with this you know Google
Facebook have come on board to support
us CrowdStrike one of the leading
cybersecurity companies has come on
board they want to help that's why it's
so important that we do this in a
bipartisan way and Eric Rosenbach who is
co directing the Belfer Center Harvard
they've been kind enough to offer a home
for this there's a lot of resources out
there we just need to get those
connected if the government comes to
that's fantastic we can I ask you about
yeah okay I didn't know that part but I
know that it's made news yesterday where
she was saying how troubling it was to
see Donald Trump circling her I'm
wondering at that moment when the debate
was over because we all saw the video
and at the time we thought that's odd
when you guys got off the stage does she
say I wish I would have said something
was it a big conversation was it in the
campaign at the time you know to be
honest Matt would appreciate to see when
you're done with those debates sometimes
it's just thank god that's over
yeah we thought it was strange and you
know I've spent a lot of time thinking
about what I would have done differently
if you think was a missed opportunity
now if she's if she had said what she
said on that tape back up you creep do
you think that would have made a
difference I could argue that both ways
who knows who knows but you know I'm
focused right now that one of my
takeaways from this election is this
hacking is a problem that's why Matt and
I have linked up you know we're moving
forward doing this hacking doesn't have
to do anything with Donald Trump
circling her Robbie
at the time did you guys go what is
happening here it we do I here's what
I'll say it when a campaign with a lot
of really weird moments and I think in
another election with other candidates
that would have been looked at
differently but
there's a lot of code of what it's so
great to see a Democrat and Republican
together in the wire
hey uncle work probably much